[Musique]
le Roi et l'Oiseau
réalisé par Paul Grimaud sorti en 1980
scénarisé par lui-même et Jacques
Prévert d'après l'oeuvre
la bergère et le ramoneur de Hans
Christian Anderson c'est pour moi le
film d'animation le plus beau au monde
le plus poétique le plus touchant le
plus beau visuellement il a une musique
enivrante du polonais qui lard la
réalisation elle est très poétique avec
des passages sombres tout en reste en
coloré alors oui c'est une contradiction
mais qui nous plonge dans un univers
justement à part entière qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de découvrir dans un film
d'animation on est totalement
à la différence du des studios de
Disneyland on est sur le tout premier
film le tout premier long
d'animation qui a son ou son chantier a
été instauré et basé en France donc on
peut ici sur ce film là par les du
premier film d'animation français à part
entière et d'un chef-d'oeuvre également
du cinéma du 7e
[Musique]
mais j'ai pas peur des enfants
il faut savoir que le film donc est
sorti dans un premier temps sous le nom
la bergère et le ramoneur comme l'oeuvre
de Hans Christian Anderson mais il a été
désavoué par Grimaud et Prévert malgré
cela le film a été jugé déjà
impressionnant et remporte un prix au
Festival de Venise avec l'admiration de
plein de techniciens dont les futurs
créateurs du studio Ghibli
et cette fois il a été primé donc il a
reçu le Prix Louis de Luc
et c'était le premier film d'animation
qui recevait cette distinction au niveau
de la thématique de l'histoire on peut
parler de triangle amoureux pour les
adultes on va parler d'une fable
politique et sociale et aux yeux des
enfants on va pouvoir parler tout
simplement d'une course poursuite
d'amour et de liberté
[Musique]